pearson the fallout from a deadly
shooting on a movie set in new mexico
has revealed safety issues involving a
member of the crew actor alec baldwin
fired a prop gun on thursday killing
cinematographer helena hutchins and
injuring the director omar villafranca
is in santa fe new mexico with the
latest
at a vigil in los angeles sunday film
and television workers gathered to honor
helena hutchins hutchins death is now
under investigation by the santa fe
county sheriff
according to an affidavit assistant
director dave halls grabbed one of three
prop guns set aside by the film's
armorer hannah gutierrez who took her
first lead armorer job earlier this year
when halls handed the gun to actor alec
baldwin halls allegedly shouted cold gun
indicating there was no live round in
the chamber baldwin later fired the gun
killing helena hutchins and wounding the
director joel souza who was standing
behind her and in a new affidavit
released last night souza told
investigators baldwin was rehearsing a
scene that involved drawing his weapon
and pointing it towards the camera lens
a 9-1-1 call from thursday raises
questions about how the gun was handled
on set including by assistant director
halls
check the gun she's responsible maggie
gall was a piro technician on a shoot
with halls back in 2019
she says hall's behavior on that set
compelled her to file a complaint with
her executive producers the first ad
they're not just steering the ship
they're also there to maintain a safe
working environment it was there any
safety concerns that you have
no fire lanes hard to access
doors were blocked there were no safety
meetings while the investigation into
the shooting continues it's not clear if
criminal charges will be filed says new
mexico defense attorney erlinda johnson
they have to demonstrate criminal
negligence that the person acted
recklessly with want and disregard for
the safety of others we have repeatedly
reached out to halls and gutierrez but
have not heard back and we're expecting
to learn more about this case at a
wednesday press conference
omar villafranca cbs news santa fe new
mexico